rodrigo de la sierra escultor y pensar
que hace 30 años quise ser arquitecto y
me dediqué a mi profesión durante 12
años
qué bueno que hubo un momento en el que
pude ver las cosas afuera de la caja
por un momento si mi voz interior y hace
15 años decidí
estudiar escultura me convertí en
escultor creé a timoteo debutamos en
japon le dimos la vuelta al mundo y ya
desde entonces pues no trabajo me dedico
a mi pasión
y es más este estoy en text platicando
con ustedes
el ver las cosas afuera de la caja se
cree que es un medio para resolver un
problema de forma distinta
es como decirle a alguien aborda tu
problema desde otra perspectiva y lo vas
a poder resolver qué fácil no para mí no
lo fue porque para mí no es un medio
para mí es la conclusión a la que llegue
a través de vivir cinco experiencias de
vida que fueron fundamentales para mí y
que esta tarde quiero platicar con
ustedes
recuerdo una
plática que dio el fundador de apple
steve jobs para los egresados de la
universidad de stanford
interesantísima yo creo que ya la vieron
todos ustedes y si no se los recomiendo
mucho por favor háganlo busquen en
youtube vale mucho la pena
el habla de tres experiencias que lo
marcaron en su vida yo me quiero enfocar
en la primera es la titula unir los
puntos
aquí básicamente lo que dice es que él
no sabe por qué tomó ciertas decisiones
en su vida hasta que las vio en
retrospectiva serio él se dio cuenta
porque lo hizo es decir a partir de tu
presente tu puedes analizar hacia el
pasado ciertas decisiones que fuiste
tomando armar un mar para un mapa mental
y va subiendo los puntos
para mí eso es la intuición
yo hasta la fecha le sigo haciendo caso
a la intuición generalmente te vas
acercando a tus metas aunque esto me ha
llevado a veces a tropiezos o que me
vean la cara yo espero que en el futuro
sepa por qué el brazo todo eso y uno de
los puntos mentales
pero básicamente
podría ser como esta obra tenemos una
barca en donde todos los personajes
están aglutinados en la popa o en la
parte trasera y hacen que la barca se
hunda en donde se puede levantar la
punta
si nosotros le podemos hacer caso a
nuestra intuición
poco a poco uno de los personajes puede
irse separando de los demás ir subiendo
llegar a la punta y poder ver hacia el
horizonte
qué estás dispuesto a hacer para
alcanzar tus sueños hasta dónde piensa
llegar
generalmente cuando tú te vas
le vas haciendo caso a tu intuición tú
vas tomando riesgos que te acercan a tus
objetivos en mi caso me acerco a la
a la carrera como escultor pero
este que no se malentienda por favor no
me arrepiento de haber sido arquitecto
ni haber trabajado como tal esto es una
experiencia valiosísima que hasta la
fecha lo aplicó pero
después de 12 años de trabajar en
diferentes empresas como arquitecto yo
estaba en una posición muy cómoda en un
puesto muy seguro en una muy buena
empresa con mucha proyección
pero había algo que me decía que faltaba
más
un buen día me levanté
y a mis 32 años de edad renuncie y
decidí volver a empezar
recuerdo una
exposición mi primera exposición
individual fue en san miguel de allende
en octubre del 2009 no se me olvida la
fecha
yo para esa época yo ya había estudiado
este
es casi 5 años es cultura y yo llegué
sin ningún recurso
a mis 36 años mis viejos tuvieron que
ayudarme a terminar la exposición
pero todo con el esperanza con la
intención de poder vender una obra desde
la inauguración les platico esto en las
inauguraciones no se vende todo el mundo
va al coctelito a hacer social y todos
hacer piar lo que menos hacen es ir a
comprar van a tomar el cóctel hito
gratis pero la buena noticia
es que si se vendió
y en menos de un mes casi la mitad de mi
obra estaba vendida
ya saben lo que hice después volví a
invertirlo en obras
el que el que no está
dispuesto a tomar riesgos va a vivir muy
cómodo en su zona de confort cómodo
seguro pero yo creo que difícilmente le
encontrará sentido a su vida
los siguientes tres puntos
parten de una frase muy poderosa que me
compartió un compañero el escultor que a
su vez se la dijo su maestro de arte
y que pueden agrupar los siguientes tres
puntos o experiencias de vida que me
llevaron a ver las cosas afuera de la
caja un artista debe sentir hondo pensar
alto y hablar muy claro
si lo vemos estrictamente dentro del
mundo del arte podría ser tu inspiración
la capacidad de inspiración la capacidad
de materializar tu idea en una obra
aterrizarla y el tercero hablar claro
sería que tú seas el juez más duro o el
crítico más severo contigo mismo para
poder materializar tu obra y transmitir
una idea
pero para mí esta frase tiene un
significado más fuerte como filosofía de
vida
la creatividad los límites y la
ejecución o hacer las cosas
recuerdo una plática que tuve con una
amiga de la primaria imagínense de la
primaria hace poco y me preguntaba tal o
cual cosa si recordaba en que fuimos a
una expedición y tal paseo
me sorprendió su memoria pero se los
juro yo no me acordaba de nada bueno no
me acordaba ni quién era ella
pero has al hacer el ejercicio de
memoria
lo que sí recordar lo que yo hacía en
ese época en esos años que para mí eran
muy bajos era que todo el tiempo estaba
fantaseando yo vivía en un mundo de
fantasía de mi imaginación nunca estaba
en el lugar donde estaba pero
bueno hace cuenta que un día me fui
disfrazado de superman abajo del disfraz
de el uniforme como si fuera a clark
kent pero eso fue en la preparatoria
fue pre primaria creo en una de esas
clases abiertas donde invitan a los
papás este
yo creo que en mi mente del niño dije
híjole si aquí las cosas fallan pues me
convierto en su verdad
no el poder de estar y el poder estar
imaginando continuamente yo hasta la
fecha lo sigo haciendo por ejemplo si yo
veo una película generalmente estoy
adivinando el diálogo que va a salir y
muchas veces le atino y
termina la película y quiero cambiar la
dirección el guión quiero
nuevos actores veo como la escena a mi
gusto en fin la creatividad es un don
innato del ser humano
es así como los pulgares que nos sirven
ahorita muy bien para chatear junto con
la creatividad es una habilidad con la
que nacemos pero que si no le estamos
retroalimentando tiende a marchitarse
imaginemos una profesión la más
poco creativa o más metódica que ustedes
piensen
contador lo bueno el papel es contador
ustedes creen que no necesito gran
creatividad fiscal donald trump para
solamente pagar 750 dólares de impuestos
abogado
robert zafiro y jimmy cochran
defendiendo en el juicio del siglo
jay simpson vieran alarde de creatividad
convencer al jurado convencer a la
fiscalía de que las huellas de que la
sangre estaba contaminada
los señores todos aquí tenemos esta gran
capacidad de creatividad el secreto del
éxito es no dejar morir al niño que
llevamos dentro
en mi caso me llevó a romper me llevó a
romper las reglas hacer que un personaje
esté en el duro mundo del arte
hablemos de los límites
para mí es simplemente no existen
dese arquímedes dame un punto de apoyo y
moveré el mundo
cuando rebasa sus límites
es como dar un salto al vacío es un acto
de fe es abandonarte es tu pasión
dejarte llevar por tu pasión a alcanzar
tus metas por medio de perseverancia y
trabajo y si lo ves de esta forma en
este punto
te das cuenta que la meta ya no es tan
importante sino el cómo va llegas a ella
decía winston churchill
el éxito no es definitivo el fracaso no
es fatal lo importante es siempre seguir
adelante
recuerdo una exposición muy padre que
tuve en chicago les platico que a veces
montar una exposición en el extranjero
no es tan fácil como lo que quieres
contratar ayudantes y te encuentras que
el sindicato las horas solamente vamos a
mover tres piezas no cuatro se vuelve
complicado entonces uno tiene que hacer
la mayor parte del trabajo imaginen la
escena porfa
estoy en mis peores fachas gorrita
camiseta empapada en sudor todo mugroso
trepado en un andamio montando una
escultura en eso entra un señor como de
unos 80 años
y se pone muy meticulosamente y muy
serio a ver cada una de las obras
cuando termina pregunta por el artista y
bajo me presento y le platico mi sentir
de la exposición de qué se trataba y
todo esto el así muy serio me estaba
viendo
y me dice
todo está muy bien pero usted no pudo
haber hecho esa obra es usted muy joven
se dio la media vuelta y se fue
este ha sido hasta este momento el mejor
cumplido que me han hecho
hacer las cosas su ejecución
aquí tengo que hacer una pausa para
poder expresar o quiero expresarles mis
sentidos del mundo del arte
para mí el arte es la plática de un
evento de la realidad a través de la
mirada del artista
transformado transformando en un diálogo
de los sentidos es un diálogo de las
emociones de una persona para las
emociones de otra persona
en este diálogo no reconoce fronteras ni
lenguajes igual puede ser interpretado
por alguien de japón de rusia de china
por un hombre una mujer un niño un
anciano
es el lenguaje de lo intangible y el
objetivo del arte es crear en el
espectador una idea que se forma una
idea que se vuelve un parteaguas se
vuelve un antes y un después
cuando el espectador queda tocado por la
obra y a partir de ahí cambia su
perspectiva su forma de pensar su forma
de sentir
el cambia y va cambiando a su vez a
otras personas
es como cuando tiras una piedra en el
agua se genera una onda que podría darle
la vuelta al mundo en sí ese es el
objetivo del arte una idea inmortalizada
a partir de que la obra toca al
espectador para este punto ni la obra ni
el autor ya pasan a ser importantes
recuerdo una
en el inicio de mi carrera una
experiencia muy padre que estaba
pero de verdad de los primeros años
estaba en el estudio y recibe una
llamada telefónica en ese momento me
dice una chica
mi nombre es tal este quiero decirte que
mi papá me regaló una obra tuya
y la puso fuera de mi cuarto sólo quiero
decirte una cosa ahí me quedé medio mudo
porque se lo dijo tan serio y yo
empezando mi carrera yo dije se rompió
la escultura está defectuosa me la va a
devolver me va a reclamar algo y le digo
adelante y mi corazón dice no te explico
yo vivo en una silla de ruedas desde
hace unos años tuve un accidente muy
fuerte y mi situación no va a cambiar
solo quiero decirte que el ver tu obra
cada día me da la fuerza para seguir
adelante
en ese momento quedé mudo con un nudo en
la garganta me gustaría poder
expresarles
lo que sentí en ese momento
el espectador interpretó la obra se
generó una idea para mí el ciclo estaba
cerrado para mí la obra ya estaba
realizada
pues
éstos han sido los 5
5 experiencias de mi vida que han sido
muy relevantes para que yo pueda ver las
cosas afuera de la caja
la intuición
los riesgos la creatividad los límites
el hacer las cosas han sido herramientas
muy poderosas que me han podido hacer
ver las cosas afuera de la caja no solo
para resolver un problema sino para
entender mi entorno y lo más importante
entenderme a mí mismo
imaginen que este círculo rojo en el que
estoy parado son mis límites emocionales
y mentales
son mi todo mi universo aquí está lo
bueno y está lo malo
supongamos que lo quiero expandir y no
puedo supongamos que lo quiero mover o
quitar de aquí no puedo
qué es lo que podría ser
podría ver las cosas afuera de la caja
yo no me siento
alguien en especial o para él en
particular para venir a dar un consejo
solamente me gustaría compartir una
reflexión con ustedes por favor pensemos
afuera de la caja sintamos afuera de la
caja y vivamos afuera de la caja no
importa que al sentir nos tilden de
locos al pensar nos tienen de locos al
sentir nos decepcione nosotros tomen el
pelo al vivir tropecemos y caigamos
siempre y cuando tengamos la capacidad
de levantarnos
recuerden que la vida es demasiado seria
para tomarlo es tan en serio gracias
[Aplausos]